last week a man with zero experience of
women's football close to zero
experience of managing a team of any
gender who had expressed no interest in
the job and had to be asked to apply for
it was chosen to manage England's women
football team Phil Neville graced the
appointment by explaining a tweets about
domestic violence and sexism and then
joked he'd scored the second best job in
football this one appointment says so
much I look forward to the day such an
inexperienced woman is appointed to such
a senior job in sport or any sector and
if you thought the gender pay gap at the
BBC was bad it's nothing compared to
prize money in sports winners of the
women's FA Cup get 25,000 pounds their
male counterparts and 1.8 million for
those who claim men's games involve more
physical exertion and I will come back
to that consider darts for male winner
of the BDO world championship gets a
hundred grand the female equivalent gets
12 grand it's the kind of blatant
grotesque discrimination I hope we will
one day used as evidence of a bygone era
how can anyone carol ever defend this
madness okay right I'm gonna jump
straight in with the pay thing alright
gonna jump straight in there alright
loads of it I could do this whole piece
for myself I love it on the paving right
right okay okay what so showing that
sports just a job right just a normal
job a run of the mill job and we're all
doing the job here alright show Merle
getting paid the same okay and you're
doing how many show you're doing if I'm
four shows and I'm doing two would you
be able if they paid if I paid me the
same as you tennis right and the woman's
playing tennis she only has to play
three sets to get through he's gotta
play five his life
nobody was paying tenants but anyway so
he's playing five sets these guys I'll
tell you what I'm working me I'm working
here and she's only doing free that's
not very fair is it so and they want to
be it strikes me what if less exertion
in women specifically that's all I say I
don't think it's about exertion that's
how much they've got to do these the
work you mentioned I suspect and
probably know that they are market
driven yes and so male football and it's
there's no I don't think there's even
any point disputing this has a
marketplace that far exceeds female
football for whatever reason yeah
largely because women don't tend to
watch the sport as well right so you
know as well as the fact that men are
watching female football the fact is
that women aren't generally by and large
the football fans and so you when you
call them are but the thing is but there
are now four female football teams but
they're still not watching it right so
when you got to mark it like that of
course if it is market driven if you
don't want a command economy if you
don't want to dictate what each sport
can do with the money that it raises
because that's what we're coming down to
at the end of the day you will bankrupt
female football if they have to put the
prize money at the same as men because
they they it's a business and they set
their own prize money based on their
market and the ticket sales have you
ever been to a woman's football match I
haven't ever been to men's there is
therein lies the problem because I
haven't been to we haven't okay so so as
we're just saying revenue and sponsors
dictate prize money when when there's a
Premier League football match the crowd
which is between fifty and seventy
thousand that dictates how much people
get and when there's a one of the best
women's teams play then the average
crowd is about five hundred the bottom
line is sponsors are not gonna pay for a
sport that not that many people are
watching now when you have something
like women's football and you use the
example you have you have men watching
men's football you have a few men who
would watch a woman's football match you
have very few women that are going to
watch one this football matches now this
is not denigrating what they do they're
very good but it's a different game and
it
you've got is a mainstream sport V and
minority sport and it's not about
equality women are never going to be
equal on the football they're just okay
you know what they especially not going
to be equal if its treated as such a
second can we talk about that are we
ready
can we talk about darts and I say
there's a reason there and I'm dying to
hear what you have to say but about I
want to talk about darts because the
difference in darts is really quite
extreme and I don't think anyone could
argue that it's based on different
levels of skill and talent am I ready to
show you I want to show you using I'm
gonna show you something to prove the
point record right first up in our
inaugural battle of the sexes it's Phil
the crafty come on down Campion ready
trouble new place and pepijn take this
Hawkins time 18 what not another one
Phil scores 20 but I'll show you how
it's done feel good in there
ready that's a night that's the 20 well
that's a triple 20 hapless chords hey
Jay
[Applause]
[Applause]
with my new passion for women started I
am now gonna join the campaign and join
that the men's dance teams they can but
one has never qualified for the
championship because they're not good of
you on that right in to some degree I
was taken on brought if you look at it
in its purity
yes it's wholly unjust and I do struggle
to see quite how mister I hope he does
fantastic things with the team I hope
they win they their respective World Cup
it was a strange appointment I grant you
that but where the reality is where
magic comes in which is at market
certificate is bums on seats and if
you're going to get billions of people
watching the men's FA Cup final whatever
literally all they used to around the
world it might have been slightly down
but certainly their Premier League is I
think the second-biggest league in the
whole of the world if not living the
same cannot be said and that is what
drives it so in pure forms you're right
in market forces do you seem to be
reasonable right about this
I think it's a vicious cycle to the day
of unusual victory and it's a vicious
cycle I'm sure you can see that because
it's the women's game is not taken
seriously they're not given us a coach
who has experience so the money is not
put into the market this is the business
into their worst enemy of the women's
sport if you if you were to apply this
because as Nick's just reminded everyone
I was right and that is that you will
bankrupt a winning sport if you demand
responses in prize money and here we
have an example of their most vocal
champion ever on TV is admitting she's
never even been to a female football
game and that therein lies
I do want to say that I do want to say
just in your defense that Phil Neville's
appoint does seem a bit weird because
actually that wasn't about the market he
doesn't seem to be even a very good male
coach people who apply for that job now
one of the biggest female football
writers in the country whose name I've
just forgotten community she said that
that a lot of good women coaches didn't
apply for the job and the ones that did
dropped out halfway through the process
so if women don't want to manage the
football team you can't blame have an
exclusive we have an exclusive with the
co-author of the first ever women's
football yearbook who has explained to
us some of the factors that are at play
here this is Tom Gary in terms of the
number of girls playing the game and in
terms of the technical ability at the
top level the women's game in England
has never really been in a healthiest
state but unfortunately the finances are
still really really struggling there's
not very much sponsorship there's little
to no television broadcast revenue and
because of those things salaries even in
the women's top-flight still pretty low
some place Saloni earning around 18,000
pounds a year and there's not very many
female referees either all female
coaches so those are the challenges for
the English women's game to really try
and correct over the next few years that
was Tom going off for it clearly a fan
or female form or somebody who's
actually doing something about it but
here you heard me explain some real
practical obstacles anyway and it's
about the market doesn't that sound
cyclical it's like they've not getting
broadcast and then they're not getting
sponsors and then they don't have any
money to pay the players and so it
remains this kind of second obstacle and
has to match where there's only 500
spectator I've just thought those are
part of the reasons why there are so few
spectators Carol because I mean I think
that the demand is there and actually if
you look at how extreme this is right
let's look at the women's super league
it's not played in a some women winners
that the women Super League get nothing
I'll make a deal here RT why make it
let's go to a female match
I'm gonna wrestle it away Aramis like I
could have played for England but I was
rubbish again I'm bitter and twisted
about it I really am